(dramatic music)
(waves crashing)
- [Narrator] The Galician coast
line in Northern Spain is
home to one of the most expensive
delicacies in the world.
Percebes, or goose barnacles,
grow on the sides of rocks
in the treacherous waters
of the Atlantic ocean.
Barnacle hunting has long
been considered a man's job
but in Baiona, a town along the
coast where hundreds of families
make a living off the ocean,
some of the best barnacle
hunters or percebeiros are women.
- [Narrator] Percebes hunting
is not for the faint of heart.
Every year there are hundreds
of accidents along the coast,
but, for the González sisters,
the risk is worth it.
- [Narrator] Part of Xosé’s
job is to keep watch over
the percebeiros while they are working.
There have been numerous
fatal accidents in Baiona
over the past decade but
Xosé has been able to save
the lives of 10 percebeiros.
- [Narrator] Three years ago,
Belén González had a career
ending accident when she
slipped on a patch of seaweed
and fell into the rocks.
And recently, Lala, the youngest,
was forced to take a leave
from the sea after going
through cancer treatments.
So for now, it's just Susana
and Isabel who hunt together
keeping the family tradition alive.
- [Narrator] To keep the
number of percebes at a healthy
level and to prevent over-
fishing, quotas have been
imposed on the hunters.
- [Narrator] The sisters
sell their haul at a seafood
auction that takes place at
Baiona fish market every day.
- [Narrator] These market
auctions have become a hot spot
for local chefs and restaurateurs
like Bernardo Alvarez Miniño
who frequents the market
every week looking for perfect percebes.
- [Narrator] Despite the
risks that come with their
profession, the González sisters take pride
in carrying on their family’s tradition
and commitment to working with the sea.
(dramatic music)